[Music]  developing news from overnight metro  police investigating a deadly  officer-involved shooting happened last  night near charleston and eastern  officers were called there to reports of  a man shooting from his apartment  when they arrived they say the man fired  a shot then ran back  into his unit as officers tried to  secure that apartment they say the  suspect came out with a gun  at this time officers fired upon the  suspect striking him  officers then attempted to render  medical aid  however he succumbed to his injuries and  was pronounced deceased at the scene  this is metro's fourth officer-involved  shooting of the year  they will release more information and  body cam video within the next  72 hours john